uh
now
all right fabulous
i
i am
under the belief that representative
rhodes is in florida still with her
mother so
in attendance today
so i'll open the subcommittee meeting on
house bill 1079
and just to remind the folks what this
basically is
is it's looking to adjust the amount of
part-time hours that a retired member
can work in the system
or that's in the group 2 system
and make adjustments forward with that
in
to give you an idea of what 16 16 164
hours looks like that equates to 32
hours a week
the current statute of 13 thank you 1352
and of course
to cover what rsa 100 a7b means that is
working
under
a declared emergency
so that's already that's already in
statute but that
in the event of catastrophe exempts
um
those hours from from even becoming a
so with that i'll be happy to
thoughts
mr chair yes my feeling is that
we changed this
relatively recently
and
we haven't really heard
major problems from it as long as the
allowance is there for
cases of emergency i don't feel that it
needs to be changed back at this time
okay
the other thing too that i'll point out
you know because we
being cognizant of what's going on in
the seacoast and hampton beach certainly
becomes the largest town in the state
you know in the summer especially on a
weekend you know looking at that that
total number of hours
you know
hiring someone for the limited summer
that we have in new hampshire here
equates to 640 hours
so we're not even in the ballpark of
concern in reference to part you know if
hampton was awry or uh seabrook was in
you know need of hiring part-time police
officers to handle beach
season
we're not even remotely close to to
having an issue with those hours at 6
40. so that i just wanted to
throw that out there as i'm you know as
we're kind of putting a reality to what
thank you mr chair and i too would agree
that uh what we have in place now is
you look around at other states and
there are other states out there that
don't allow
retired workers to even come back and
work
we've
met a balance
as to
with the separation from employment 28
days
we allowed four
police officers to maintain their
training and their certification in
those 28 days
so that they can come back
you know we we've talked about this
numerous times and if anything you know
the number of hours could actually even
be reduced
when you're retired
you retire not to retire to come back to
work in the same position you were
and in these cases they can come back
they could retire and
someone could retire if we get rid of
the language in this bill if we left
past this bill right now that's here
before us
you have individuals that could retire
in april
and still work full-time
for
the summer months collecting a full
pension and working full-time and i have
an issue with that
it's also been brought to our attention
in the reference to those that that are
in the teachers in group one that this
would
exceed their actual full-time hours so
in essence you could have a teacher
retire
and just continue to work full-time
under under this
almost under the current numbers
absolutely when we go beyond that to
over 1600
and that's my concern and why i say you
know if anything i'd
would be for reducing the hours
so the other concern that i that i have
again in
in discussion here um is twofold one of
that involves
the
income stream to the pension system
we've made a lot of changes over the
years that have
been done down to the guise of reducing
benefits but it's also
shut off an income stream and where the
retirement system relies on investment
returns to function
we have to be careful as to how many of
these income streams we shut off
and that's my concern with what the
quote unquote decertification
problem in the sense that an agency can
eliminate
a full-time position that pays into the
not only is there an issue in reference
to their debt
as assigned to that position but also it
shuts the income stream off completely
and
we have to be careful
with that
because we do heavily rely well not
heavily right now it's an e it's about
what 85 15 i think 85 percent of the
members contributions covers
the payouts and we re we rely on about
15 percent of investment returns
but i don't want to see that number
start to change
certainly that that's in it you know it
would it would be great frankly if it
was
you know if we didn't have to rely on
investment returns at all but that's
just not reality so
um
so there's there's you know that is a
function in this and the other thing too
before i get to you mark is um
you know we in 2010 there was a you know
there was a lot of looking at the
concept of double dipping and we had
some some examples in the state of new
hampshire where that was occurring you
know and this
really doesn't this goes in the other
direction when it comes to the concept
of double dipping and that's
both structurally and in the sense of
public perception has been something
that's not really gone so well so
you know i think that we have to be
careful here
um
bringing back something that literally
goes against what we fought for in the
cases of double dipping representative
thank you um
this one is a tough one i see problems
on both sides of this issue all around
i understand the
on the one side unless i'm thinking
confusing this with another bill and i
don't think i am
um
on the one side you've got the issue of
people retiring but then
not ideal and it makes for um
makes for problems with personal
relationships and and
you know
the possibilities of corruption
on the other hand
if a person has worked x number of years
fully vested in their pension and
and is beginning to receive that pension
well that they've worked for and they've
already paid into it so it's theirs and
what they do beyond that
is really no business of anyone's
frankly
on the other side the the i see the
problem of um
you know streams of income for the
pension system
but
the flip side of that to me is
again they've already paid in their
pension
so what their working
situation is beyond that i mean they're
not sucking money out of the pension
system
uh that they haven't already paid
into
although i do understand like you say it
represents a decrease in income
for the pension system
on the other hand uh
you know
not getting more money isn't the same as
losing money so i'm i'm
have a completely open mind on this and
i'd love to uh be convinced one way the
other not easy
sure one one of the things that is
healthy
and this is some you know i get some
people that just that have a hard time
with this concept
but
the it's better for the pension system
for an employee to work longer
right because they're paying rather than
collecting and even though that gives
them a larger pension as they move
forward
overall for the system it would it's
better for employees to work longer
that's part of the reason why the change
in 2010
changed the minimum amount of years from
20 to 25 because it was it was just
overall it was healthier for the system
it wasn't necessarily healthier for the
employee but it was healthier for the
system so
this is one of those things where i
we've we've also we've done two things
here you know let's also not forget
that when this was enacted there were
approximately 2 000 employees that were
grandfathered as well
and they're so they all they're still
all out there those folks are still
can still function with absolutely no
limit
you know and that's of course they will
attrition will get you know we'll remove
them over time but
um that's it's going to take a long time
for those 2 000 grandfathered retirees
to be
in essence to die i guess i mean that's
really how you that's the only way you
attrition out of the pension system so
um
so yeah i don't think that you know i
haven't seen a compelling argument
really as to as to why this increase is
necessary other than
some communities just don't want to
annie up the money to to hire
the full-time people that they need so
um
i mean that's i think we're kind of all
on the same page with that
we also saw mr chair
that there were some cities and towns
that were going away from full-time
positions
creating part-time positions and when
they do that
they walk away from the unfunded accrued
liability portion by doing that and what
that does is spread that out amongst all
the other communities in the state
so when you when you
remove a position from
a full-time paying into the system
position and you make it a create a
part-time position you've also walked
away from that unfunded accrued
liability payment on that position as
well so that's one of the other issues
we had and that just goes back onto
other cities and towns picking up that
rate
it you know and i think until we until
we really address
how that's dealt with
specifically
i i think we need to be cautious here
about
further adjustments
because as of right now statutorily
it's not well addressed
as to how that's dealt with and i think
that that's something that
there needs to be legislation in the
fall
not not that i'm encouraging the
creation of another commission or
committee
but i think that we there needs to be a
look at what we need to do statutorily
to say to a community know if you've got
you know if you've got five million
dollars worth of pension debt you can't
walk away from it by simply just making
all your people part-time that's not
fair to the other communities so
so i think that that that really
warrants um
a deep dive before we start
well you know i guess the
it would really come down to if
representative allegro has any
other questions or concerns in this
matter
here we go
i'm just having a problem sorting out
which is the
the greater of two evils but it seems
that the rest of the committee or
subcommittee i should say
um is of one mind
and um
so it's not three to one i think it's uh
uh
and i yeah i don't have any questions i
yes
i may the question is not whether the
retiree should pay into the retirement
system on the hours worked nobody
believes that should happen the question
is should the employer pay into the
retirement system to cover the accrued
liability of the position that is now
to be are they to be paying
once he's retired we want the town to
consider its obligations
and a number of towns and school
districts have told me that they
specifically hired
retirees so they wouldn't have to pay
the pension contribution on those on
no doubt it's just that you know
basically in this particular piece of
legislation there's no that's not being
addressed
at all it's this is simply just asking
do we adjust the hours in a calendar
you know there would there could
certainly be some discussion as to
whether this is amended to to start
talking about the specifics of that but
i don't know
i mean do we have to get a ruling if if
this is going on beyond the original
intent
as far as it being germain or not and
and again i don't you know the the
representative that filed this
representative trottier
wasn't really in his address did not
really touch upon that at all it was
really just a matter of
and i agree that would that would be a
complete uh
tangent off of what the intent of this
bill is so you know again looking at
1079 as it exists
you know it's basically a matter of what
is does this committee agree that the
number of hours should go up and i and
it's pretty clear that they do not so
um
i think we should leave this as it is
it's only been changed it's only it's
not even five years old that these hours
have been changed so i think that you
know i think a little bit more time
needs to happen here to look and see
um
you know what that translates to and
and also too keep in mind and i want to
be clear here this is not
this is not a limit on the number of
hours an agency can do this is a limit
on hours of a specific retired employee
so this is not handcuffing a
you know a department from hiring two or
three part-time people
it's just there's there's no prohibition
there it's just a matter of per employee
so i want to make sure that
that that's understood we're not we're
not harming
you know a a police department
that has a need here they just they're
just gonna have to do it with more than
yeah okay so unless they're
limited by the number of potential
employees available under those
circumstances they could be limited
but if there's an abundance of employees
that want to come back part-time they're
okay
yes representative goalie and just one
last thing as we talk about the hours um
we saw in
the executive orders from the governor
he
exempted them
from the number of hours they could work
during the cover relief in one of his
executive orders so it does work in a
time of emergency when these officers or
firefighters or anybody are needed in
that time
so it can be done
all right very good
that was a concern of mine also the
the fact of taking out that language for
the
28 days
and
the fact that
we do understand that there are
emergency situations that need to be
covered and i think
this bill doesn't really
help either of those situations so
and i'll just remind the committee one
more time rsa 100 a7b
is the one that allows
working under a declared emergency the
the limits just that don't apply so
that's
you know that's already in statute that
that is irrespective to what happens
with this
so cool i think uh so if there's
anything more i think the committee
the committee has made it pretty clear
that they're not in favor of this
so
all right i'll close the the
subcommittee hearing on 1079 and
hand the room over to
representative lekkis who's got a 930
subcommittee mr chad do you need a
motion
if you'd like a formal motion we can
form a motion uh itl sure
is that you making the motion no i
believe that's me putting words in your
mouth
all right
and i'm certainly in favor of that as
well
so my understanding is that this is not
an official vote right so it's a
subcommittee recommendation yeah i can
abstain right now and think it over
all right we've got a few minutes i'll
wait until the official starting time to
let me be necessary
youtube because the subcommittee is
recording now they know okay that's why
everybody's got to be in their seat
instead of us
halloween yeah okay
actually
carol thank you
i think we have to sit at our seats he
was saying because they are
recording these and
i mean i don't be sorry i'd prefer it
that way but
um
yeah for valentine's day we don't go out
because the restaurants are crazy i'll
pick up
yep
so i guess representative rhodes is uh
still in florida helping her mom with
i was wondering that as well um
but i guess her mom broke her hip
and representative marsh
so far unless somebody shows up at the
last minute
and it is 9 30 so i'm going to open the
subcommittee work session on house bill
1192.
um
so the senate has a bill senate bill 282
which they've amended
and passed on the consent calendar
which does i think everything we want
i mean i've got a few copies of it in
case somebody wants to see it as amended
by the senate but
it's going to come to us anyway
so
my suggestion is to recommend that we
just hold on to 1192
until we get senate bill 282
and then um we can decide what to do
which will probably be
you know i would say probably to
review and and go go along probably with
282 and then it'll 1192 but we can wait
the issue is we won't get senate bill
282 until after crossover and we have to
do something with this house bill 1192
prior to crossover
um
i don't know actually
carol go out walk out anyway um bills
will be coming over over time they don't
all happen at crossover and since
they've already acted on the bill we're
probably going to see it before
crossover maybe
maybe
in any event my recommendation is we
either send 1192 to interim study or we
adopt my amendment 0 3 6 8 h which would
make 1192 identical to senate bill 282
and and then the question becomes smooth
right i talked to chair mcguire and she
you know
wasn't happy with the idea of having two
identical bills one house one senate
um i don't i mean if you look at in
january we had a whole pile of um
on consent of itl bills that were there
because the other body had done
already done it or other similar reasons
but we don't have to decide that right
now
if we recommend holding on to it we can
decide that later any other thoughts
i agree with what you're saying i think
we just hang on to it and when we get
house bill 282 if it is what we want
we use that but
i don't think we need to
we can ask the the clerk
where senate bill 282 stands but
um
i don't think that i think we'll get it
before crossover
yeah as i recall from last year we the
bills were uh
senate bills were coming in well before
crossover so
but again i mean if we come down to the
deadline where we have to act on it we
can do something with it but
okay
i'm okay with that so we just recommend
doing nothing for right now okay if we
have a consensus on that then i close
the uh
subcommittee work session on house bill
okay
oh
which is always a good sign
and they said they're completely
satisfied with what the senate did oh
well that's cool then
that's even easier if they're happy
feedback
schmidt
uh
good morning everyone
good morning those of you in the world
of youtube
this is the
executive departments and
administration's
public hearing on a non-german amendment
this would be amendment
2022-0399-h
attached to house bill 1330
representative jacobovic this is your
non-germain amendment so you have the
floor sir
these uh
we had a subcommittee that worked
through the bill and that's where i
introduced the amendment and it needs to
go to the whole committee and have a
hearing
uh the amendment
so what we discovered in subcommittee in
yes representative goalie
if this is a public hearing on an orange
main amendment i'm just curious as to if
he should be over here with a pink card
filled in or how does this work
is my question if it's a no injuring
yeah i mean it's
it's a it's an amendment
we i mean if you want we can have him in
the hot seat
sure
okay
oh
if yeah the microphone's very necessary
so if that's not going to work
we are so that
see if we can figure it get somebody
if if we can't drag a microphone over
there we may have to
wiggle things around a little bit
now it works
okay
oh there we go i have power and a
microphone
all right representative
thank you
all right
michael ikobovich of hooksett merrimack
introducing the amendment um that
was the result of our subcommittee
so the amendment deals with medical
technicians the registrations of medical
technicians of new hampshire
and
we discovered after
conversation subcommittee some
conversations elsewhere that new
hampshire is the only state that line
systems medical technicians
um then we discovered also that
negative technicians uh
are supervised by doctors they don't
really have a place to work outside of
and
general consensus among
the
the subcommittee and some
outside conversations with
uh
parties involved and uh our
representative doctor i believe
also
spoke in favor of just repealing the
board and simplifying our statute
that's where i'm at so this is the
amendment that's what it does it's thank
you
representative could you uh elaborate as
to why under
on lines 12 and 13
you've struck out
an rsa
is is is 328i
is that the section that covers medical
technicians precisely yes since it's
been repealed elsewhere references
elsewhere throughout the statute needs
to be cleaned up cleaned up
right so that's what all those looks
like
got it
no it makes sense 328 it is it is the
chapter
all right wonderful thank you does any
member of the committee have any
questions for representative yokovich
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
we've heard
a number of times in testimony
that
we were the only state that does this
and i'm hearing conflicting information
i've heard
there may be 11 states out there
that either register
do you know if their new hampshire is
truly the only state doing this or are
in my belief new hampshire is the only
state but
anyone else
from the committee
seeing none thank you representative for
mr chair
yes represent goalie could we have
our researcher look into that
information saying this isn't a timely
bill and
we have a little bit of time to get that
the chair calls senator sherman
did i see senator sherman
he's not here yet he asked me to put in
the card because he's under time
constraints then we will switch over to
miss
bizarro is that am i pronouncing that
correctly from the new hampshire
good morning
members of the committee for the record
my name is kathy bazar with umberg
executive vice president new hampshire
hospital association i'm here this
morning to testify in opposition
to the amended version of house bill
1330 and i just wanted to share a few
comments one is that the new hampshire
hospital association
representing our member hospitals are
supportive of the original bill as
introduced house bill 1330 which would
change
the board to an advisory
capacity
the reason why we believe that the med
tech
registry is important is because
several years ago
and i think this is something that
senator sherman will address
is that we had a very serious situation
in our state with a
cath lab technician that
stole
opioids for his own use
and impacted
the access to care for patients as well
as infecting
many patients with hepatitis b
those are very serious patient safety
issues which is one of the reasons why
this med tech board was created to begin
with
there are several types of positions
that are
covered under the medtech registry and
again i just want to also clarify this
is a registry this is not a license so
this is just a list of professions that
are registered with oplc as being in
practice in new hampshire
that have access to opioids and patient
care
so the list for the record of those that
are part of the registry are anesthesia
technicians
cytotechnologist
diet technician or nutritionist
assistant
emergency room technician
endoscopy technician
histology technician histology
technologist
lab assistant or lab specimen processor
medical assistant
medical laboratory technician
medical technologist
paramedic
phlebotomist
poly sonographer or sleep lab technician
registered respiratory therapist
senior medical technologist and surgical
technician
i also wanted to address a question that
represented goalie asked about other
states that may license
these types of positions i believe the
11 states do
laboratory technicians as licensed
lab techs do fall under new hampshire's
registry so we don't license them in new
hampshire we register them
so there are other
of these other positions that i
mentioned there could be other types of
registry certifications or licensures at
other states new hampshire took the
position of registering these types of
positions
so with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions of the committee
thank you very much representative
allegro
the uh technician that kicked all of
this off by the theft of controlled
substances were they excuse me i want to
shift over so i can
actually see you as i'm speaking to you
were they not prosecuted for that theft
they were
follow-up please so then there is a
powerful legal mechanism to deal with
people who
do things like that then
i think the point of
of being a registered
position is that
there is an opportunity for when you
hire someone if they have already been
registered if there was any
discipline against them in at least in
the state of new hampshire i think under
the original intent by senator sherman
and i would hope that he could be here
and speak to this he would love to see a
national registry of these types of
positions but felt like because there
was nothing in new hampshire we needed
to start somewhere so at least it's an
opportunity for a place for people to
file complaints and understand if
someone is in bad standing thank you
representative schuett
thank you mr chair
do you recall
how many deaths that
medical technician that was prosecuted
caused
i don't recall that number off top of my
head there were some people some of the
patients that did
decease though is that correct correct
in new hampshire and in other states
where this particular person had
practice thank you
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman and thank you
kathy for taking my question
it seems like one of the key questions
here is whether other states in fact
require
registration or certification or
licensure or whatever of of these kinds
of people and i'm i'm looking right now
at the website of
the american society of surgical
technicians and while it looks like new
hampshire is the only state that
specifically requires registration only
of these technicians who are in contact
with opioid
who have access to opioids
it looks like they have a list of 12
states and i'd be glad to to read them
that require education and certification
of surgical technologists and an
additional three states require surgical
technologists to register in order to
work
does that match your understanding yes
thank you very much
representative fellows
it seems to me a little strange like
this
registration is called
technicians
medical technicians but when you told us
the list of people that were in there
a lot of them sounded like positions
other than what you might call
technicians
so
um
one of the things i noticed just by
googling not that i know anything about
hospitals or medicine or anything like
that is that some states
have a registry
or a licensing process for people who
have access to
controlled drugs
and i'm wondering if we're calling it
medical technician but really is it more
trying to
protect trying to identify people who
have access to controlled drugs yes that
is the intention of new hampshire's
registry is specifically for
health care professions that aren't
otherwise licensed for instance rns
they're not in this list but they have
access to controlled drugs but they're
already licensed by the board of nursing
so the list of positions that i
read off for you are those that aren't
otherwise licensed or certified by some
anyone else on the committee have a
question representative goalie
thank you
so
we hear
that
licensing and registering
individuals and having boards
is for the best interests
and safety of the public
and
hearing that
deaths were related to some of the
things that went on in the previous
individual
would not registering these individuals
be in the best interest of public safety
representative lekis
thank you
um i'm just wondering if you happen to
know
if the the person you mentioned who
basically committed a number of crimes
if registration had been required would
he have been eligible for registration
because it appears
and let me know if i'm wrong
that
the main thing would be if there was a
if the
med tech registry had been in existence
when this individual was hired into new
hampshire he would have been required to
register in new hampshire
follow-up
i understand the question was
was there anything
in his history when he started to work
that you know of that would have
prevented him from being registered
my what i'm getting to is you know would
the existence of this registry if it
existed before he was hired have
prevented him from being hired and and
then going on to do what he did
i don't know the specifics of the hiring
details but um
i see that senator sherman is here and
he had been intimately involved in that
situation he may be able to answer that
question for you thank you
representative o'brien
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i imagine is a host
of federal
regulations when you're dealing with
controlled substances within the medical
community
and
other than the federal regulations and
everything
does this particular bill
enhance that and provide some proper
safeguards can you just go over that
does it add more than what is currently
under the federal regulation
the bill before you which is an
amendment to house bill 1330 repeals the
board so it certainly takes away patient
safety considerations
with the original house bill 1330
changing it from
a board to an advisory capacity still
allows for
these members of the profession to be
registered and have oversight by oplc
anyone else
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls representative excuse me
senator sherman my
thank you mr chair and
members of the committee
i would like to speak strongly against
the repeal of of the
board of registration although
i
as long as the same
as long as an advisory board
would have the same ability to register
technicians
so in
i was asked to form a new gastrointest
gastroenterology group in new hampshire
in exeter their group had pulled out
with only about four to six months
notice
and i was commuting to massachusetts so
they asked me if i would come and
start this i'd i'd run a 10 physician
practice in virginia before and um
so it was really exciting
and about a month after i started we
hired hillary tompkins who's one of the
best gastroenterologists i've ever
worked with and she's phenomenal she's
coming straight out of training
we're a fledgling group
in
2011 we started having cases of
acute hepatitis c
and in all my career
i'd never seen acute hepatitis c
it's a chronic illness typically people
who have had exposure to transfusions
[Music]
needle sticks or um
and you know people like hemophiliacs or
people who were who had substance use
the treatment was incredibly difficult
at that point some of you may know that
we were using interferon and riboviron
which
can just have terrible side effects but
there were great new drugs in the
pipeline
mass general had a study on these
one of the hillary and i were sitting
there literally at about 5 30 after we'd
finished seeing all our patients and
we're puzzling over two charts
they were both patients in their 80s
you know not your classic hepatitis c
patient
and
neither of them had any risk factors for
hepatitis c
so we started going through the charts
together saying this is weird
the other thing to know about hepatitis
c is that you don't usually show
symptoms so
hepatitis b you typically will get
jaundice you know yellow skin yellow
eyes
yellow urine or dark colored urine but
not hepatitis c it's only a small
fraction of people who who will actually
manifest symptoms of hepatitis c
so these two elderly gentlemen
had acute hepatitis c by their blood
work
but they were also symptomatic and
that's what flagged us that there was
something going on in them and that's
why we did this this check
turned out the only thing that connected
these two gentlemen
was the cardiac catheterization lab
at exeter hospital
and
you know the aha moment was a horrific
aha moment because the implications were
that if this was correct or if this were
correct
then
everybody going through the cath lab
was at risk
so we called the
hospital they notified the state
and many of you who were here in the
state back in 2011 2012 that's where the
hepatitis c outbreak first got its start
shortly after that working with the
hospital association and others we
started the statewide steering committee
which was an incredible group every
single stakeholder in the state
who was trying to we were devoted to
trying to make sure that no one else was
impacted by drug diversion
the impact was enormous and this gets to
representative likus's
say your last name is lekka sorry
representative leckus's question
um in the state of michigan alone
the guy who was eventually found guilty
of this kotowski had gone to five
different hospitals in the state
they had no way to track him he was a
radiology tech
so what he would do is he would take
the anesthesia or sorry the cardiologist
or if they had an anesthesiologist was
laying out the fentanyl
for the next case they had it out on the
sterile field
and then
so what kutowski would do was he would
take the fentanyl
inject himself with it
draw up another syringe now remember
when he injected himself that needle is
now dirty
he'd draw up another syringe
the same syringe put it back down on the
table
so the patient number one didn't get any
got some of kotowski's blood every time
it would be like it was somebody
suffering from substance use disorder
sharing needles that's exactly the model
and we know that in
in addiction when shared needles occur
within the first month if you're sharing
needles you have about an 85 percent
chance of getting hepatitis c
so that's how how contagious it is once
you have even droplet level trans
transmission
the state
i'm sorry the the u.s attorney
whose name
it was
john cacaves
was brought in because this was clearly
a criminal case
of drug diversion
we ended up with 32 people
in just the exeter community
infected
one of them was the very close relative
of one of our republican state senators
and who eventually died
so he became a very strong ally of ours
um some of you may have known senator
cataldo
and
then jose montero who was the state uh
chief medical officer for the department
of health and human services they did
their own investigation
and there were i think it was two or
three state reps
from exeter and stratum one of whom is
tim copeland who actually i spoke to on
friday
tim is a retired new york city detective
and to him this was criminal and we
needed to make sure that in the state of
new hampshire we did everything and i
think you were with me on this um
we need to do everything we possibly
could to make sure this never happened
again
so
we put we got tim to participate because
he was a state rep on the statewide
steering committee and we started
thinking about legislation
and essentially we did four pieces of
legislation out of this
because what we learned
was that
kutowski fell into this gap
of people who had access to patients and
access to controlled substances but was
not listed anywhere in our state's
regulatory system
so you know physicians i'm
i'm
overseen by the board of medicine pas
board of medicine rns
the nursing board
we've since formed the
board of radiology technicians um
senator carson and i did that together
so
but all of these
have are regulated except this one group
of
in a broad term of technicians
or assistants
who
have access
to substance use i'm sorry to controlled
substances like kutowski did
and also have access to patients like
was trying to figure out how to define
this group
it's a really diverse group of
professionals
you know some are radiology tech some i
work with endoscopy texts
we have techs in offices we have
and so you don't want to get every
single medical assistant you don't want
to get every single endoscopy tech you
don't want to
if they don't fit into this gap
the very specific definition of those
with substance use
and
i'm sorry with the controlled uh
controlled uh substances and access to
patients
so we actually it was a re-referred bill
or i'm sorry it went it was in the house
so
we worked on this for a year and a half
or at least a year and brought it back
uh with pretty much unanimity
to close that gap
and that's what the board does
it's these are not people who are
certified they're not licensed so we're
not looking at competency
we just want to know who they are
and
you know to follow what we saw happen in
if there had been a board of
registration
he would not have been able to jump from
hospital to hospital
and if you know the story he actually
ended up going to 16 hospitals before we
caught them
in
new hampshire
and the only reason we caught them was
because our little fledgling group
got every patient from the exeter
catchment area into one gastrointestinal
group or liver group otherwise if i used
to practice in lowell if it had been
lowell he
we have you know eight physicians and
are actually now 10 and two separate
groups
this might never have been discovered
but because it all comes into one funnel
um
we got all of the patients that he would
have impacted
nationally
cacao said that he would have impacted
that the people he put at risk we were
over 8 500
people
8 500 people
and there were deaths not only in our 32
patients but also nationwide as a result
because of course they did they went
back and looked at oh my gosh you know
what about hepatitis c he was at johns
hopkins
he was down in texas
five hospitals in michigan when they
back when they traced it back
all of a sudden there were deaths that
were being attributed to this guy's
behavior
now you may say wow all of this in
response to one outbreak
it's not one outbreak drug diversion
this was my fifth case that i knew of
that had touched my practice of drug
diversion
and i point you to
one just before us
that was out in denver at rose memorial
which is an hca hospital and they had
multiple deaths
a huge hepatitis c outbreak and that was
the exact same it was actually an
anesthesia tech which would have fallen
actually even more so into our board of
registration
so the definition
of medical technician
is one that we came up with to capture
this group and then we further refined
it by saying only medical
technicians with exposure
to patients and access to controlled
substances
so the idea was to regulate as few as
possible more like a scalpel than a
sledgehammer
as few as possible but
to make sure we capture
so we don't have any gaps in
all the people that we're keeping an eye
no behavior that would make it
so we don't want them practicing the
state of new hampshire
there were several national articles
about this afterwards and we talked
about the board i was interviewed for
one of them we talked about the board of
registration for medical technicians in
that our hope was that new hampshire was
the first
but that it wouldn't be the only
as long as it's the only
it only protects us from people who are
moving from hospital to hospital within
our state right
it doesn't really protect us from
somebody coming in from out of state
except that once they're here if their
pattern is they start going you know
once
kotowski was found down on the ground
with syringes in his coat pocket
syringes of fentanyl and he was just
fired this was at one of the other
hospitals of those 16.
nothing was reported police weren't
called he was just moved on
that would not happen in new hampshire
as long as we keep this registry intact
because there's no place for that person
to move on to in new
hampshire um
we also put in place drug free drug-free
workplace requirement for all licensed
health care facilities that was another
bill these were all strongly bipartisan
and
the really telling news is that we've
not had another significant outbreak or
drug diversion case in the state of new
hampshire since then
so that's the historical background
for where this came from
as i said i'm absolutely fine with it
being something that doesn't require
quorum but still has the oversight and
registration
and it stays as narrow as
as this one is i don't want to regulate
everybody i just want to regulate those
who put who have a real chance of
putting patients at risk
so i'll stop and take any questions
anybody has
representative lectus
actually i'm shocked that uh the
hospital would would find something like
that and then do nothing but fire him we
were too yeah um so my question is
given that
um
you know would this person even given
his
behavior another state let's say they
had a similar registration procedure
you know
why would it be if the hospitals aren't
going to report anything or do anything
why would the registration board even
become aware of that behavior
i don't i mean it's a
horrible thing that happened a serious
problem but it's not clear to me
um that this would actually have
prevented it
that's a great question and it is up to
responsible hospitals or employers
remember this could be an outpatient
surgery center or something like that or
or an urgent care area that has
one of the one of the reasons that was
cited for them not reporting was they
had no real mechanism to do so that you
know it's either
you know we call the police or we do
nothing
and
honestly it's criminal behavior and they
should be calling the police
um but we've we know that that's not
always the case but
if you're terminated
like he was in that case
that has to go into the registry the
reason for it
and
it's
for the hospital it's not a high
liability they're required to do that so
it gives the hospital a much
even if it's just suspicion you know
they could potentially let somebody go
but it gives the hospital an in between
to report and it is a requirement it's a
requirement for a licensure so
were they not to do that
that would be a problem the other
problem is that this is also
self-reporting you have to tell why you
were terminated and
that
can generate an investigation my partner
was actually my medical practice partner
was actually on the board when it
started and helped to form it
um
and
he was really amazed at how
two things one is
when you have a board
it's a very it gives due process to
discipline
but also
he saw people
applying to come to the state of new
hampshire
with
you know you get the initial application
it would have some discipline issues in
the background
and when they realized that they were
going to be subject to review they
withdrew their application
so it is a deterrent as well as an
active monitoring system
and if we take this away we're back to
where we started
the recommendation to do this was not
only the recommendation of the steering
committee but also of the department of
health and human services and also
also the u.s attorney's office
everybody recognized this gap so i would
ask you
with all due respect not to
reopen the gap
follow-up
um you
mentioned that the employer would be
required to
report
at least the reason for termination and
maybe other things i'm not seeing that
in the goals at all right
it is
um
actually the way it works because this
was one of the four bills that we
got in place is that
you know
if you have if you terminate an employee
for cause
and they go to another place and that
person
asks you say say concord hospital in
exeter hospital exeter hospital there's
somebody who has a discipline problem
you terminate that employee they go over
to concord hospital
concord hospital calls exeter hospital
and says
what happened why are you why why did
you terminate this person
exeter hospital you know in the old days
might have said
they were
all they would give was yes the
effective date of termination was x
one of the bills that came in gave
indemnity to
exeter hospital to report exactly
why the person was terminated
and that was part of these to make sure
that that communication when patients
lives are at risk that that level of
communication is open and that the
hospital if they report honestly
truthfully
then they would not be subject to
litigation so that was another one
because the hospitals weren't disclosing
problems just one more follow-up i could
sure you understand i mean a number of
uh
businesses the liability issue around uh
providing that information so
is it just that
they're uh
you know they they're not liable in that
case or is there actually something that
requires them
to report it to let's just say the board
of registration or anyone else i can
pull the statute i don't remember the
wording but my rec my recollection is
that they have to report
that but that they are protected in that
reporting
representative marsh uh yes uh thank you
mr chairman thank you senator for coming
before us and help explain what was a
really confusing thing for those of us
who are new to this
my my understanding looking at the
registration process in the original
bill
which is page 1 lines 22-27
is really two things are going to be red
flags for the people that are problems
first is the pending criminal charges
that may not be evident unless they're
required to report it and second of all
is the work history which means
people who go from place to place to
place to place are generally the ones
who are a problem is that your
understanding as well
yes and um just
as you know
representative dr marsh
all of the other professions
in healthcare have a national
reporting
between states it's not federally
overseen because that that's not
something that you know it's like
insurance the
is left up to the states to create their
own boards and their own regulatory
system
but they're all
speaking to each other
so if i
if i apply for
medica to the medical board to become a
physician in new hampshire
they query not only the practitioner
database
but also they will query any other place
where i've had
a license in the past and that's a huge
benefit to the people of new hampshire
to make sure
we're not having a bad apple from
maryland coming to new hampshire
to cause trouble here and then be a
problem for the board
um that is that was our hope when the
board of registration as i said to to to
stop people like watowski from bouncing
from state to state
he learned after michigan after going to
five different hospitals he better get
out of state and go to some place fresh
and new and so he became a traveling
tech and that's how he ended up bouncing
i it there are states that have done
some form of this board of registration
but
my
comfort in this is that at least we have
it in new hampshire and and we've
representative bailey
hi
thank you for taking my question
um
this seems to be kind of after the fact
i'm sort of puzzled by i think you said
8500 times this person was left alone
with the drugs
isn't that really the place where you
need to pay attention rather than right
oh yeah three years ago he was in this
other state or
so
there's two ways that that's being paid
attention to uh thank you
thank you for the question it's a great
question
after the rose memorial incident
um
what the anesthesiologists were doing at
rose was they were drawing up all the
medications for the next case
and then having them ready you know
you're doing and and i hate to sound
medical but you're you're taking care of
a patient you've got a little bit of
downtime while that patient's asleep so
you pull up the drugs for the next case
put those out on the table for the next
case you're ready to go right you're
you're all prepared
that's when the tech
you know you'd start turning over the
room the tech would be alone in the room
they could
swipe
those medications from the
anesthesiologist the same thing was
the practice
standard practice across our state
of preparing for
a cardiac catheterization does not
require an anesthesiologist
so the cardiologist just like i as a
gastroenterologist can can
have people using i i can direct the
nurse to give fentanyl and versed to my
patients that's also the case
in a cardiac catheterization
so
while there's no anesthesiologist
necessarily involved there is still the
preparation of the medications and and
if they are preparing them the case
before
then that's the opportunity for the tech
that's pretty much moved out nationally
for two reasons one in in the state of
new hampshire that steering committee we
identified that as a problem and it's
not standard of practice anymore in the
state
but two
there's two major accrediting
groups that go to every hospital in the
country they usually pick one or the
others one is called the joint
commission and when the joint commission
comes through they make sure that these
practices are no longer ones that that
can put patients at risk
the 8500
is the number of patients that he had
access to
in a setting where controlled substances
were involved that doesn't mean that he
did this 8 500 times but that's the
number of patients that would have been
at risk over the period of
those 16 17 hospitals including us
thank you
representative judy
thank you mr chair good morning good
morning uh after 8500
this guy's still
out there or he's in jail right now he's
in prison
he's in massachusetts he's he got 30
years
only
uh and there's actually a documentary on
it there's a so this this made national
news i think it was newsweek or time
chronicled his journey through the
and as i said it was just
luck that we were able to put the pieces
together
does anyone else have a question for
senator sherman representative scitec
senator sherman are is there drug
there is
um in fact you know i mentioned five
one was a gastroenterologist in leesburg
virginia i was practicing in manassas
and
when he went to jail
his patients came over to us
and
they were amazed that they were actually
asleep for their colonoscopies because
he was
stealing the drugs that were supposed to
be used and they were very uncomfortable
my reaction is as follows
i
i'm blinded i have trouble looking at
this because
none of this should have ever happened
if there were proper background checks
if the trustees of the hospital weren't
scared about this guy being found with
the needles in on them and
let's hush this up i i have no such
knowledge but i can just picture such a
thing and
i'm
feelings settle down
i might be able to look at this a little
bit but i'm thinking
you've told me or you've this man
koskowski
criminal conviction
lots of
hospital hopping suppression along
we're looking at the tail not the of the
dog
my story i'll match your story there was
a teacher at my high school
known by all the teachers in the high
school who was doing things with a
mentally challenged young woman
he left he's teaching in lawrence until
he retired
nobody no can't say a thing
so i'm i'm having difficulties with this
perhaps wrong cure for societal
difficulty and i'm i can't really wrap i
can't sort that out
well i share
your
i mean it's deeply troubling no matter
how you look at it i'd i'd really
recommend you go and read if you want to
get more troubled read that
piece in in i can't remember whether his
time or newsweek but
you know when you look at
for example
nasa you look at
really great hospital systems you look
at health care systems the stakes and
hopefully school systems the stakes are
so high people's lives are on the line
and in my world
trust
is the fundamental that's on the line
you know when i go to my doctor i put i
trust them to do
and when there are techs in the room or
nurses in the room there's a huge amount
of trust you just can't avoid it but
there are huge amount of redundancies
built into the system
and for example you come in for a
colonoscopy i'm sorry to keep inflicting
colonoscopies on this committee but
when you come in
in the old days
you've probably heard of wrong sight
surgery have you ever heard of that
there was a person who had the wrong
kidney taken out and the other kidney
had cancer
so they lost both kidneys
i mean that's unforgivable right
so in colonoscopy you come in
and you're going to have a timeout that
means not you you didn't do anything
wrong not like if you were a little kid
but
it's a time out where the whole staff
makes absolutely sure not only who you
are
but also that we're doing the right
procedure
that's called a timeout that has come
not because it's a great idea but it's
come because with all the checks and
balances we have all the people doing
the intake people still get the wrong
kidney taken out
so
this may not this is clearly not the
only answer to making sure we don't have
another outbreak or drug diversion
but it is a part of that redundancy in
the system that is has very low impact
on somebody who's not doing anything
wrong
but in terms of catching somebody or
deterring somebody who is intent on
criminal activity like drug diversion
this is one part of our repertoire one
part one arrow in our quiver
to make sure it never happens and i'll
tell you as someone
who then
had to treat those 32 patients
afterwards it was
uh
i can't really describe what it was like
in those times there was one gentleman
who we got through because all we had
available in the early parts of this was
this horrible combination of drugs
riboviron interferon
and i would see him every week during
the course of his treatment
and when it was over
he cleared the virus and
we celebrated together
senator sherman my
my mother was having a procedure done on
one of her knees and took it upon
herself with a sharpie to right wrong
knee on her other knee smart when she
had discussions with the doctor after he
or the surgeon he was uh not thrilled
at that i would have been thrilled at
that i have patients who actually put a
dotted line across the lower part of
their back and said if you can read this
you're too high up you know it's
it's for a colonoscopy but you know the
more
the more we do
to protect ourselves and our loved ones
the better as long as it's not
overdoing it and that's why i think this
closing the gap
we worked really hard and if if we're
wrong if there need to be tweaks that's
that's great
but we worked really hard to get the
definition
that was imperfect but really captured
the smallest number of people
in that huge group of professionals that
make up medical technicians
that would actually be regulated
so that you know there's a cost and
there's work that's done on the registry
side and i think i think we hit the
right balance
but um you know i'm always open
suggestion i just would ask you please
don't repeal it because it is
one while it may be redundant it may not
be perfect
it is one of the things uh that we have
in place to protect patients in new
hampshire
representative judy yes thank you
senator i'm back again
um
after infected so many people
because um i'm trying to say this is
public record he was one of the patients
that was in the group
so
you know when you have a whole bunch of
80 year olds
who are infected or people with cardiac
disease then you have
one person
who
is infected with the exact same strain
you know we can subtype hepatitis c just
like you've heard of omicron and delta
and all that we can do the same thing
with hepatitis c so we can it has a
fingerprint
so you follow the fingerprints and
thank you mr chair
senator
you stated that
you were okay with the underlying bill
which makes this board advisory
but would it be your preference to
actually not do anything and leave the
board just as it is in law now
not necessarily because you know they're
having trouble staffing the board
really what i care about is that we
register people
and that there's adequate oversight if
you just register people and you don't
have any oversight that doesn't help
much
in fact it's a waste of everyone's time
so
if they're registered and
they meet and they have essentially the
same function i don't think it has to be
necessarily at the level of a board
but
just so long as the function and the
protection for patients is the same
anybody else on the committee have
questions for the senator
representative fellows
thank you um just on this last issue
i'm wondering
if you
if the board is just advisory and not
if if their advisory that seems to imply
that they can't make any decisions
so
[Music]
if somebody if that gentleman were to
have
applied to be
a tech in new hampshire
and the background
check shows
that
if if the board is only divi advisory
i'm concerned that he will just slip
through and be registered i'll jump in
on that one representative fellows the
way the bill's written this would fall
under the office of the executive
director
so this would not this would not be
something that would slip through a
correct exactly my concern
that
it would be doctors and medical
professionals
that would feel comfortable to say
this person
we don't we don't want this person i
mean i'm not talking about if he's been
convicted that's totally different right
but to see something
suspicious or that needs follow-up
i'm concerned that somebody who doesn't
have a medical background is not going
to identify that there's an issue there
well i'd answer that
with two things one is i would defer to
what level of oversight she would
anticipate they were able to provide
two is that
she would have access or i would have
presumed this board would have access to
all the different
if they had a question about the
clinical side on the other hand
i think one of the reasons one of the
drivers for this bill is that they just
haven't been able to staff the board
with health care professionals and
i would i don't know if mike padmore has
spoken yet but i'm generally what we do
is we
hear from the boards that they need
staff like the board of medicine the
board of nursing they'll go to the
nurses association
and then we get volunteers for them to
serve on those boards and i don't know
if that was ever flagged for the
hospital association or
the
board of medicine that they were having
i'm sorry the medical society that they
were having problems staffing these
boards
but
if they weren't talking to the societies
that's probably why they weren't able to
follow-up
um
we've we've heard from many um we've
heard reports on about many boards not
just the medical ones that have a
difficulty
you know holding a quorum in and getting
volunteers
do you think if we were to add
alternates
to
the board then that would make it easier
for it for them to be available and
also we've talked about it it's not in
any bills if they could participate via
zoom
you know that might work it might not
work for for things when you're talking
about
a specific individual but some
strategies
like that other than just making an
advisory
well anytime
you ask
any professionals to participate in
something that's volunteer
that takes them away from their day job
it's it's difficult and i think you know
we've seen that
during covet we've seen that but
i think number one alternates would be
very helpful
uh number two is um
there is a benefit to being in person
uh just
being able to see each other like today
being able to look at you all in the
eyes and make sure we're all on the same
page and that i'm really answering
representative lexus's question
um
but
but you know the reality is that virtual
for some of these boards would probably
make participation easier and
facilitate people volunteering for it
because
you'd get people from all over the state
which is the other benefit is that you
get a much more diverse
group of
participants
do we have any questions for the senator
before i cut them loose
seeing none thank you senator sherman
happy to come back if you have more
questions
that's going to be the last pink card i
have concerning
this public hearing on the non-germain
amendment
i don't mind at all
but i'm gonna i'm gonna trust that since
you are an orange bed you have a rough
understanding of the procedures of how
we operate here
so
let's let's make sure we uh
thank you mr chairman um for the record
my name is mike padmore and i'm the
director of advocacy with the new
hampshire medical society um i did want
to just come in and testify um and just
share our opposition to the the
non-germain amendment for hb
1330. i'm not going to repeat uh what
senator sherman has outlined already i
think that he did a great job of
explaining the background of why this
board was established what i would
simply just say is
from our perspective this is just a
patient safety issue
as practices are
hiring building out their practices
you know they want as many different
resources
at their disposal as possible
to make those decisions this is
certainly one of those resources
so i would just simply say please don't
take that away
and i think to one of the questions and
forgive me representative the the chair
is just in the way of your name so i'm
just missing uh uh your name but uh this
would be representative scitec scitec uh
sorry about that um i did just want to
say so you had brought up an analogy um
of
an abusive teacher in schools what i
would simply just say is it's one of the
reasons why i think we have a sex
offender registry
it may not catch that first instance of
abuse but certainly the hope and the
goal is is to then prevent those abuses
in the future and i think the same
concept does follow with this obviously
um in the instance that senator sherman
had outlined in the early 2000 or early
2010s
that first instance had gone on for many
times
but the hope is i think is that if there
is a registry in place it does at least
help prevent those those abuses in the
future it may not prevent every abuse
but if it is one additional resource i
think the hope is is that it can help
to prevent those abuses moving forward
so
i would just conclude my testimony by
saying you know please
please don't repeal this board we do
feel that it is a helpful resource um
to our physicians in the state to our
practices in the state and i'm happy to
yeah i do have a question and that's
this
suppose at a given hospital in new
hampshire some
some personnel technician doctor
is uh
caught stealing
and he's fired
when he goes to another hospital or
another wherever and asks and they ask
uh you the original hospital
why did he leave what would that
hospital say the original hospital
i to
thank you for the question um i don't i
don't know specifically what they would
say but i do think in the case of
physicians you know they are regulated
with the board of medicine so there at
least is that aspect of oversight that
physicians do have from a professional
standpoint
and
as as was stated by um
from earlier testimony the reason why
this board was established is because
these professionals don't fall into any
of those um
those established boards so this at
least would provide some oversight to
those individuals to your question on on
the physician who's who's fired by uh
one hospital
i i can't speak to that specific
instance but at least there is that
mechanism of the board of medicine that
has oversight uh and and a complaint
certainly could be filed uh by a
hospital to the board you know let
making the board aware that that a an
let me refine that a little bit suppose
the doctor is let go because
he maintains his credentials but he's
just not a good doctor they don't like
him he's just
careless whatever but he keeps his
credentials so they quietly he's out the
door what's the next hospital here
when they ask
do you re the hospital the original
hospital
so
is the question what would that what is
the recourse at that hospital what kind
of reference would he get
i i mean i suppose it would come down to
if that if that uh that hiring hospital
had reached out to to the hospital prior
uh depending on what the cv uh what the
physician's cv looks like you know that
is that is on the hospital that's hiring
to to go through the due diligence i
guess what i'm just saying in terms of
this board is that this is one of those
resources
does any other member of the committee
have questions for the
gentleman
seeing none thank you for your testimony
is anyone else in the room wishing to
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing on the
non-germain amendment
that is the final thing that we have the
only thing that we have as a board today
or as a committee today um is this
um
this hearing so at this point we're uh
don't forget to sign in on the sign in
did you watch the super bowl last night
you